hello everyone and welcome to the events
that follow the final round of the cter
Masters 2023 uh we have a tiebreak game
between Notre yakub and notbe abdat and
even though uh Arjun nesi went into the
final round as the sole leader and uh
had he won his game against Abdus satov
he would win the tournament and if he
got a draw it would probably mean that
uh either he wins or he tie breaks with
someone else and then they go into tie
breaks but uh you've seen what happened
in the previous video that I made he
blundered uh in after a grueling game he
blundered with a uh a terrible skewer
with with the bishop he blunder the
piece and uh well that just means that
Notre backck and other Notre backck
yakub are now in the tie breaks and this
is the uh this is the last game I'm
going to show first game went to yakub
he um won very nicely and now abat needs
to win this one with the black piece in
order to force further tie breaks now uh
the time time for per it is 5 minutes
per player uh now they are playing Blitz
kind of a silly I feel that you have to
tie break a classical tournament with a
Blitz game uh but what are you going to
do it has to be decided somehow and uh
yes the two of them have played together
in the Olympiad as you know last year
usbekistan won first place in the chess
Olympiad here you have a nice photo of
them uh the entire team uh and now uh
remarkable here in a tournament where
160 players competed that we have two
grand masters from usbekistan battling
it out for first place uh so let's check
it out yakub with the white pieces opens
with D4 we have Knight to F6 uh Knight
to F3 E6 and now Pawn to C4 we have
Bishop to B4 check uh going for the BOGO
Indian defense and uh in the last video
that I played I mentioned that uh when I
go for the BOGO Indian and my opponent
plays Bishop to D2 sometimes I block
with A5 sometimes I go Queen to A7 but
here uh Notre does nether he actually
goes back Bishop to E7 it's the only the
fifth most popular continuation but uh
it's a Blitz game you have to surprise
your opponent as much as possible and he
needs a win in this game to force TI
break so Knight to C3 we have castles
and pawn to E4 and now Pawn to D5 a very
sharp variation uh in top tier chess it
has been seen before for example in St
Louis 2019 Fabiano kwana had it against
Sam Shanklin Fabby played D5 with black
their game ended in a draw H we have
Pawn to E5 Knight to E4 and now uh there
are some games where Bishop to D3 was
played also C5 is a know move but here
we have C captures and D5 and already as
of move eight we have a completely new
game so e captures on D5 and now Bishop
to D3 piling up on the Knight here so
Knight captures on D2 winning the bishop
pair Queen captures and now uh Knight to
C6 so you might consider also playing
something like C6 and then maybe get the
Knight into the game via Knight A6
Knight to C7 uh but Abdus satov goes for
Knight to C6 right away also put some
pressure on the D4 Pawn uh we have
castles and now a bishop to G4 uh of
course you would very much enjoy
capturing this Knight and also you are
putting more pressure on D4 as the
Knight is defending on D4 sometimes you
have to be careful even if it's not
defended then you might run into some
Bishop captures on H7 tactics where your
knight will just hang but here Bishop to
E2 solves all of the problems and now
Pawn to F6 challenging yakubu a strong
Center we have Pawn to H3 Bishop to H5
and Rook 8 to D1 uh King to h8 always
useful especially in a Blitz game and
now Rook F to E1 we have Bishop back to
F7 uh supporting the D5 pawn and Bishop
to B5 now uh we have Bishop back to H5
threatening the Knight and Bishop back
to E2 yako of course satisfied with a
draw here uh it's Norbeck who will have
to figure out how it's Abdu who will
have to uh figure out how to look for
some progress here so Pawn to A6 we have
Queen to C2 and now Bishop to F7 of
course the idea is Queen B3 you will put
pressure on the B D5 pawn and also on B7
so Bishop to F7 defending the pawn pawn
to A3 now we have Bishop back to G8 here
the bishop nicely defends the D5 pawn
and also the H7 Pawn uh if you're going
to ever need it so e captures on F6
Bishop captures and now Knight to A4
going for that C5 square and you cannot
prevent it with B6 as the Knight C6
would hang so here Queen to D6 preparing
B6 but now Knight C5 again if you play
B6 then you hang the A6 Pawn uh but
Notre has to win this game and he does
not mind sacrificing a pawn to get some
sort of U an initiative going so he
plays Knight to d8 we have Bishop to D3
and now Pawn to B6 he sacrifices the A6
Pawn Knight captures an A6 and now
Knight to E6 uh we have uh here okay
you're going after the D4 pawn and he
probably maybe thought okay he's just
going to win it but uh yakub says Nope
your C7 Pawn is hanging as well if I
eliminate the Knight on E6 so he plays
Rook captures on E6 uh sacrificing The
Exchange Bishop captures and now Queen
captures on C7 uh we have Rook a to d8
and now Rook to E1 putting pressure on
the bishop here so Bishop back to G8 and
now yakubu have trades Queens we have
captures captures and now Knight to C7
the Knight has to figure out how to get
back into the game uh he will go via the
B5 Square Rook to C6 Knight to B5 and
now Pawn to G5 uh we have King to F1 uh
it's the end game so you have to
activate your king um Abdus satov does
the same and now Knight to E5 attacking
The Rook here so Rook to E6 and now Pawn
to G3 we have Rook to E7 you would very
much of course enjoy doubling up here
but Knight C7 just Forks The Rook so you
have to prepare it uh so uh Rook to E7
and now Knight to D6 not allowing the
doubling on the D file and also this
diagonal is now very very strong also
the Knight coming to F5 could be very
unpleasant for his King so Bishop
captures on E5 uh yes you do have the
bishop pair but in Blitz uh it it is the
Knight that Reigns Supreme of course
everyone knows that Bishop captures on
E5 D captures and Bishop to E6 putting
pressure on the H3 Pawn so King to G2
and now Rook to C7 here with H5 Notre
Beck is uh very much still in the game
but after Rook to C7 he allows uh one
move that yakubu have missed uh the move
is of course Pawn to F4 doesn't matter
if you capture or not because F5 is
coming even if you trade F5 is coming
then F6 this is Unstoppable so this is
uh definitely a way to seize the
advantage uh but okay after Rook C7 this
is Blitz Knight to B5 was played
attacking The Rook Rook back to F7
doubling up on the f file and Rook to E2
nicely defending the F2 Pawn we have
Rook to E7 and now Knight to D4 uh
Bishop to D7 H5 still very much keeps um
Abdus satov in the game but Bishop to D7
loses the game on the spot and I'm sure
you guys don't even need to pause the
video to figure out why uh of course for
them it's easy to make a mistake like
this as they've played a grueling
tournaments of nine rounds of classical
chess and now they still have to play
blades TI breaks and of course uh
mistakes will happen uh but uh you see
that Knight to F5 check will Fork the
rook and the queen uh the king and the
only uh the only piece standing in your
of this accomplishment is the bishop on
D7 so of course Pawn to E6 and now you
cannot stop this and this you have to
choose what uh what to give so Bishop to
C8 was played and now Knight to F5 check
for King The King and Rook so Rook
captures on F5 Bishop captures and King
to F6 and it looks like okay you're
going to win the E6 Pawn you're still in
the game but look at this G4 and uh no
yeah it simply does not help you and
even if you go for this bishop captures
white happily trades captures captures
captures and captures
uh it's uh completely winning for white
it's king and pawn end game up opponent
yes black does have the pass to D Pawn
but it doesn't matter King F3 King E5
King E3 you cut off the the black king
for example D4 check King D3 nothing to
to be done here if if you go after the
king side pawns uh then uh you don't
even have to capture the D4 Pawn you
just play A4 B4 A5 and you've created a
pass Pawn black is just much too slow
here for example B4 King captur A5 and
uh this is okay in three moves white
will have a queen so after G4 abdat has
to figure out something else he plays
Pawn to D4 he wants to give his pawns a
bit of a head start if uh s such a such
an end game occurs but now King G3 we
have Bishop to uh A6 going after the
Rook here Rook to E4 and D3 and okay now
the the pass Pawn is dangerous but Rook
to D4 just puts the Rook behind the pass
pawn and now the pawn is attacked King
to E5 now you cannot capture as The Rook
is hanging Rook to D7 and you cannot
trade if you trade uh then the pawn
Queen's on a dark Square the light
Square Bishop is helpless to prevent
this so after Rook D7 King to F6 was
played and now King to F3 we have Bishop
to C4 H but now just Bishop captures on
D3 and he was in this position on move 4
D9 that nbe abdat resigned the second
game uh as there is nothing more to be
done here and Notre Beck yako wins
cutter Masters 2023
uh ABD had like I believe one second on
the clock when he shook yaku sand um but
and while you could maybe play a little
bit on there there really is no point if
you go for Bishop captures on E6 then
just Rook captures on E7 and after King
captures Bishop captures on H7 you're
going to be off two Pawns of course
completely winning and if you go the
other way around if you go Bishop
captures on D3 then just Rook Capt and
again okay uh Rook end game but down two
pawns again completely winning which you
know you probably could contest a little
bit if you're really super motivated but
I don't think U Abdul satov was already
at this point plus he knows that of
course this is completely winning and uh
chances are well I mean yeah you will
lose this like like maybe you you don't
lose this one game out of a thousand
maybe uh so after Bishop captures on D3
He resigned and Notre Bea Kubo wins
Katra Masters 2023 and these are the the
final standings if you got are
interested um after the tournament so
yakub and Abdus satov sort of Shar in
first place until the tie breaks yakub
comes up on top with seven out of nine
then with six and a half we have a whole
bunch of people Naran sarov hiar nakura
arji par makesh with six out of nine
David paravian M kakan Anish giri Alex
shimanov re tumv salm s abano puranik
and Magnus Carlson in 16th Place and
Magnus was very very close to losing the
the last game that he played but he
somehow managed to to get a draw in that
Rook end game uh which I didn't think
would happen I thought he would be just
disgusted with how the tournament went
for him and that he would just lose the
final game uh but no he actually you
know fought very very hard and very very
long in a completely dead lost position
and he was able to to get a draw uh so
yeah that's the game and a little bit of
info about the tournament as far as the
ratings go I can even you know read them
out if you guys want so Magnus Carlson
lost quite a bit of rating points he
lost 11.2 rating points he's now on
2827 Fabby won eight points but that's
from the US CH Chess Championship he's
now on 2794 so very close to Breaking
2800 again uh Hikaru lost some two
points so nothing spectacular but he's
now tied with alira fuja with TW
2777 so if they will be you know giving
up giving out one spot and who has the
biggest rating it will go to to one of
them depending on how you know their
next couple of games go and then we also
have Anish lost eight points he's down
to number seven in the world Wesley
basically the same lost one point raer
lost one point Anand lost six points uh
2747 we have guesh also lost 12 points
so he's now down to number 12 uh again
uh not in the top 10 and I don't know if
we have any big Winners leevon lost um
14 points but that's also from the US ch
Championship param makulu won uh 19
points also in this tournament Vincent
up six points uh who we have here vladis
Aria also up 16 points I don't know
which tournament he's playing exactly
Mart rosian also up 12 points and you
know pretty standard stuff we have uh
currently 36 players uh on this dat that
I'm recording this uh that are over 2700
and usually you will have between 35 and
42 uh not no more no no no no less uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank Eddie
Indus bullet thriller.com Chads Smith
Sam's giant tortoise farm and ganpathy
mury for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day